do you think it's art on this episode of
dudy well I don't know if I never been
enough they are among
us
back
yest everything you're thinking will be
the things I
say I made the world inside and then
they do that and then it goes in there
and then we go in there what's in there
we're in there welcome to dudy welcome
all it is a dudy full day I am your
reigning defending Undisputed dude's the
episode Champion Will Sasso I am merely
Chad culin sitting to the right of the
champion of course this is dudy an AI
generated podcast that has access to all
of williz data all of our information
and it uses that information to tailor
the show to our comedic sensibilities
yeah yeah it sure does Chad and I like
to say that uh yeah dudy does its thing
it runs the Wheels of Steel uh but
without me and my pal Chow over
here you know it's all for not we are
dudy we without us D can't do the things
that uh D does and this is going to be a
very interesting episode with regard to
what D does you know what I me agree
yeah anyway with us as always is oh Jee
[__] [__] treat it with
uh uh
lulio Ito this means the Italian Street
dog and look at him he's just having a
little rest inside his binky bunker
doesn't want to be distur come on oh got
to get him I gotta get him and give him
a kiss he's my friend that always miss I
oh you know it's just a oh he smells
like a nice cinnamon little Ginger Snap
treat give him a kiss I don't like to
give him a kiss right on the mouth all
right one day oh oh my boy oh my sweetie
boy he's my sweet friend that follow me
around everywhere again and again and
again hey Lully what's been going on
lately you been hanging yeah yeah I had
the good weekend I watch the chief's
Dolphins game oh you enjoyed the Chiefs
Dolphins game lul yeah yeah I like I
watch the game and uh uh tyor Swift
she's a there you know she's a support
her boyfriend
uh Travis Kelsey and uh you she dancing
back and forth very happy and I Chad I
think you're right I think that maybe
she going to replace Asher to do the
Super Bowl Lifetime show wow I thank you
L I'm glad that you agree with me
finally yeah sometimes your theories
they make sense other times they don't
oh oh I love I love you so
much keep on your back and put you back
into your little space where you go
welcome to the 88th episode of dudy I
hope everyone had a great week mine's
been pretty interesting and we've
certainly got a lot to get to so let's
Jump Right In then will we're going to
indulge in another round of impression
optimization with impression
optimization 4 Arnold
Schwarzenegger then I want to hear what
you both thought of the first ever MTV
Video Music Awards in a segment I'm
calling what videos used to be like back
then and we're going to wrap Today's
show up with a Frank conversation about
the brand new UFO video released last
week in our final segment are they among
us or not [__] yes dude okay sounds like
fun yeah I can't wait for that one okay
yeah yeah there's a bunch of [__] that
like the MTV Video Music Awards thing we
know about that cuz we watch it on our
patreon but I'm going to do something
right now you may like this you may not
like this but uh at the end of our dudy
after dudy I think last week I said
eventually I was going to calm my shot
about winning that [__] belt I think
after what just happened how you were
kind of [__] on what D did guess
what what I'm calling my shot I'm taking
the [__] belt at the end of this God
damn show mark my words
today okay the belt's coming back home
Chad you [__] I'm calling it oh shot
cold well this will be hilarious I can't
wait to [__] take this title in not
just through
2024 as the smart booking says on Roman
Reigns who is uh undefeated as the uh
WWE Undisputed Universal Champion I'm
taking this title all the way through
next year M it's coming with me until I
get I'm going way past your record of 31
and this is going to be staying with me
cuz that's the smart booking but do you
pal you just said whatever you said a
lot of [__] I think you got about let me
see here um 45 minutes to hang on to
that belt and then I'm taking it home
yeah you're [__] you're funny dud is
formed an astonishing partnership with
DraftKings UFC 297 is bringing a stacked
fight card to Toronto and throwing down
on the action with draftking Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
UFC will take your excitement level
north of the Border new customers can
bet five bucks to get 200 instantly in
bonus bets we've got Neil Magny at plus
260 against Mike Mallet at minus 325
you've got Rock Hill Pennington at plus
140 against Myra Bueno s Myra Bueno
Silva at minus 166 and in the event
you've got Shan Strickland atus 135
against dricus dupes at plus 114
download the draftking Sportsbook app
with code dudy duesy new customers bet
just five bucks on UFC 297 and get 200
instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking Sportsbook with code dudy the
crown is yours gambling problem call 1
1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call 8778 Hope
and Y or or text Hope NY 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
8887895118
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance see dk.com MMA for eligible and
deposit restrictions to terms and
responsible gaming
resources you're a funny guy you both
brought up some interesting points
thanks for weighing in doing
impersonations is lots of fun so let's
keep the fun going will my little itty
bitty darling my dear you do a great
Arnold Schwarz and neger impression but
we both know it can be even better so
open up that impression optimization
folder let's put your Arnold impression
through the paces and see if we can't
get it to the next level this is
impression optimization 4 Arnold
Schwarzenegger begin
I [__] love these
dude Impressions can always get better
yeah sure okay so you're offended no I'm
not offended I'm just saying like you
know the the the the the guyger's
perfect I get it I've been doing that
[__] thing since the guy mentioned
Mad TV there I used to be on the sketch
show there and I do a bunch yeah do in
person did Arnold Scher but dudy says we
can make it better so let's make it
better because I love dudy I love making
uh this show with my pal Chow over hereo
and I love everyone if you have tuned in
thank you so much and thank you for
subscribing on YouTube thank you for
subscribing on your platform of choice
uh with regard to podcast hitting that
notification uh Bell doing all the
things especially the PODS of pal of
dudy out there who uh enjoy [__] like
this and that's why we do it and that's
the end of that sentence okay so here we
go we're GNA do a I'm gonna tune up my
Arnold
I don't know why we do this all right
okay here we
go let's get this Arnold into fighting
shape Jesus I'm thirsty it's almost as
if I ate a bunch of pizza sunflower
seeds Baseline
Baseline
okay nine
[Music]
two hold the [__]
on I just got to read the the the
Baseline words I know I'm sorry nine 2
4 [__] Aston assumed ASD acted
astonished at aston's
aspirations as an
astrophysicist acting alone at the Aspen
asparagus assembly sure okay uh that was
good I hope he got some data out of that
uh limit breaking okay will let's see
how many times you can okay okay say
okay let see how many times you can say
yeah as Arnold Schwarzenegger in a
single breath Chad you count then try
again and see if you can beat it cuz I
go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I understand
I don't know if I'll be able to count
this accurately but I'll do my
[Music]
best
yeah I think 57 okay let's try again but
I don't know wait wait wait I think that
was 57 I'm not positive all right well
I'll be I'll go way over 57 now try to
give the same accuracy please count
along if you're if you're enjoying the
pcho okay here we
go
you're picking me out what are you doing
here we
go I think that was 53 a
[__] whatever yeah I didn't take a big
enough I did I got improve my it started
like slowing down and tapering off when
you're were out of breath breathing that
was fun one oh here's one
musicality please sing allent town by
Billy Joel to the best of your ability
as Arnold Schwarzenegger of course yeah
well I don't even need to look at the
lyrics well we're living here in allent
town and the closing of the factor is
down out in Bethlehem him The Killing
Time filling out forms standing in
line yeah parents fought the second
world war our fathers they fought what
our fathers fought the second world
war spent their weekends on the Jersey
Shore May the mothers in the US Soul as
them to dance dance with them slow
and we're living here in allent town but
the restlessness was handed down and
it's getting very hard to
[Applause]
stay oh nice they living here in allent
town okay that's that's all of that
sound like you're trying to replace
Billy Joel see you see what happens you
see what happens when we do things you
understand what happens here with dudy
things happen Okay Okay situational
awareness please do a brief impro
improvisational monologue as Arnold
Schwarzenegger in the following
situations three of these coming out of
a movie theater in the middle of the day
to sunlight so bright it temporarily
blinds you and you accidentally get hit
by a car okay
okay uh I really enjoyed everything car
too ah it's so bright outside hey I
forgot cuz they inside the movie and the
movie is so long I forgot that is the
daytime but it's still the afternoon hey
Jim Cameron how many more avatars do you
need to make you only made the two
Terminators and now you're making three
and four and five avatars that's too
many
avatars to to have he's just saying this
to himself as he's stumbling around
blinded by the well I'm getting kind of
hungry look across the street there's a
el poo Loco I
guess he gets hit by a car the carit
good stuff good dude uh number two
waking up at 3:00 a.m. craving your
favorite pickled eggs but when you get
to the fridge you discover your
daughter's fiance is already there and
he's he's eaten them all common that's a
very relatable situation yeah happens
yeah hey
Russell I don't know what are you doing
you're not eating my eggs those are my
prized pickled eggs your [__] I can
only get those in one little shop in
Santa Barbara to get those eggs they're
those pizza flavored the pickled eggs
they taste like egg they taste like
pizza and they taste like pickled yeah
yeah Russ this is [__] you can't
marry my daughter anymore you get out of
here you my eggs I can't believe [__]
rust what a piece of [__] yeah Rusty um
uh being asked to give a speech at your
8th grade geometry teachers funeral oh
my God you know the the uh you know m m
Gonzalez she was an
incredible teacher there
to do geometry for me when I came from
Austria I had education but then I had
to relearn this stuff oh no she's in you
know in High School Mrs Gonzalez she
taught me about all the different uh
geometries you know that they have
there's so many there's a
parallelogram I knew it I knew this [__]
was coming the
quadrilateral the cube the sphere
there's even the shapes like a rectangle
Cube you know a circle and M M
Gonzalez she taught me all of this and
now she's Tak her final resting place in
a rectangular cuboid the cofen
shape all right that was good that was
great scene workor please read
this oh this is [__] silly stuff hold
on a
sec Chad don't burp I'm taking a drink
I'm not even burping close to it careful
it's got carbonation in it scene
workor please read this iconic monologue
from Miranda Priestley in the devil wees
Prada as Arnold swarzenegger of course W
that was Merill Street yeah okay uh this
is literally a [__] monologue from
the devil we
Prada this
stuff
this is a classic
scene there's already there's already
like your I could see you the duel
between professional actor and
Schwarzenegger impersonation happening
right now that's great I a professional
actor by trade I don't know you know you
know you you pretend to be all sorts of
things you do pretend pretend all right
this
stuff oh okay I see you think this has
nothing to do with you you you go closet
you select oh I don't know that lumpy
blue sweater for
instance because you're trying to tell
the world that you take yourself too
seriously to care about what you put on
your back but what you don't know is
that that sweater is not just blue it's
not turquoise it's not lapis it's
actually
[Laughter]
culan you're also BL unaware of the fact
that in 2002 Oscar deara did a
collection of Cerulean gowns and then I
think it was e Sant wasn't it who
showered ceru who showed ceran military
jackets I think we need a jacket here
and then ceru and quickly showed up in
the collections of eight different
designers then it was filtered down
through the department stores and then
trickled down into some tragic Casual
Corner where you no doubt fished it out
of some clearance bin however that clue
that blue represents millions of dollars
of countless jobs and it's sort the
comical how you think that you made the
choice that exempts you from the fashion
industry when in fact you're wearing a
sweater that was selected for you by the
people in this
room from a pile of
stuff thank you thank you thank you
moving on thank you D and that's why
this is can you imagine if if schz Egger
would have been in that role actually in
that movie in double Wars prod instead
of Mer street that wouldn't have made
much sense to some people but it makes
sense to me cuz I'm also the guy who
believes that Jay Lethal should have
played Ric Flair in the iron claw uh
wonderful movie with uh hopefully dudy
can hook us up with both of those pieces
of media very soon
wow will you just increase the
laughability of your Arnold
Schwarzenegger by 3% Now That's What I
Call optimization by the way if you
haven't taken a trip to the lobby yet to
visit dudy store.com you might want to
think about it and take your time
there's a lot to see dudy logo t-shirts
good job boner mugs other dudy t-shirts
other dudy mugs and don't forget to get
two of everything just in case you slip
in a puddle of motor oil or sauce and
ruin your clothes and break your mug you
don't want to have to explain being
covered in oil or sauce and also have to
explain why you're holding the fractured
remnants of a mug handle to your date
that's not what love stories are made
out of now on with the show yep on with
the show actually right now this is
usually the part of the show where I
read uh comments mostly from our YouTube
uh from our wonderful audience out there
uh but I've had an ass full of comments
for today I would like to just get can
we D can we skip the comments today
please sounds good to me champ okay last
week I had you guys watch the very first
MTV video music awards from
1984 now that you've had time to sit
with it I'd love to hear what you both
thought of what videos used to be like
back then and what the experience of
watching it again was like this is what
videos used to be like back then begin
unreal we had a great time uh as we're
sitting here now last Friday on dudy
plus which is a patreon.com dudy uh we
watched the 1984 Video Music Awards uh
we smoked some gabis and we watched that
2 and 1 half hour show the entire thing
is available now head on over to
patreon.com dudy if you want to check it
out what a [__] gas holy [__] it was
40 years ago and things were different
yeah it transported me right back to
being whatever seven or eight years old
watching that when I was a kid and just
the I I don't know if this is like I'm
getting old and it's just like it was
better in my day but it seemed like to
me everybody who was on that
stage uh was just the big
music person in the world I'm going to
look it up actually they were all super
famous it was like uh David Boe Van
Halen Madonna yeah dude Michael Jackson
obviously it just seemed like everybody
was a giant iconic music legend and I
feel like now we have Taylor Swift maybe
bad Bunny's in that realm there's a
couple of people like that but it's not
like it was there there's it just isn't
like it was I don't know how to put it
in terms of how influential music was
absolutely Duran Duran they were there
cyer yeah she was there too uh the this
is the list of Live musical performances
from that show Rod Stewart did
infatuation Madonna did Like a Virgin a
very famous performance where she's you
know rolling around on the stage there
huy Lewis in the news did I want a new
drug David Bowie did blue jean Tina
Turner did what's Got to Do With It zzy
top did Sharp Dress Man and Ray Parker
Jr closed the show with Ghostbusters and
it's a good thing that a fight didn't
start backstage between Huey Lewis and
the News and Ray Parker Jr I want also
wanted this is I'm just on Wikipedia
here I got to read you the list of
presenters that and it's like eh
whatever we're [__] old heads um you
know and so when we were kids this would
have been Ed cotch Cindy loer Roger
dalry Grace Slick and Mickey Thomas uh
from Starship uh Ronnie Wood deryl Hall
and John Oats they're in a big lawsuit
right now with each that's that's sort
of weird Peter Wolf Dale AIO all right
well maybe it wasn't all that great I
don't know who that Rick oich mck Jagger
uh Andy Summers and Stuart Copeland from
the police uh Herby Hancock John Landis
Rod Stewart and Ron Wood got they were
[__] drunk and that was amazing uh
Billy Idol Simon Lebon Belinda Carlile
Eddie Murphy and Joe Piscopo and uh yeah
the this this thing was and David Lee
Roth uh Van Halen won award and David
Lee Roth went up there and was just it
was it was so cool to be transported
back uh Dan akroy and bet Midler were
the hosts they did a [__] amazing job
it was bet Midler essentially doing just
calling from her you know cabaret shows
and and and uh one of the many talents
of hers that made her famous just
running off the [__] mouth and Dan
akroy was classic Dan akroy yeah and it
was also interesting I I thought to look
back at like the short form music videos
which really at that time were kind of
blossoming into an artart form unto
themselves Michael Jackson had just just
done Thriller which like cracked it open
it's like this is what you do in a music
video it's not just uh your record label
gives you like $5,000 and you go off in
an alley somewhere and [__] around yeah
that's what they did in the 90s with a
lot of piece of [__] like grunge videos
and just like some here put a sepia tone
on that [__] roll around in a
forest somewhere and then there's a a
performance part that's usually in the
corner of a [__] warehouse but the
videos that we're winning well I don't
know if I never been enough and I'm a
little bit
what they did though in this 84 one the
the videos that were like really lauded
were the cars uh video you might think
yeah you one video of the year that was
video of the year I got right here some
of these things and as you as you uh as
you point out but if I may yes cars you
might think was revolutionary because it
was one of the first music videos to use
a computer to do some of the animation
in it rocket Herby Hancock's rocket was
another one that won a bunch of awards
and that video literally had no human
beings in it it was all these robotic
machines just kind of [__] moving
around and that won a shitload of awards
La cream La cream and Kevin Godley we we
discovered discovered La cream La cream
it spelled lol cream in the old you know
like the creme yeah uh c r e m uh LOL
cream and and and Kevin Godley of of the
uh of the rock Duo Godly and cream yeah
or creme uh L cre had directed a bunch
of videos and and uh Kevin Godley and
they directed rocket which as you say no
human beings in the [__] thing yeah
and it won a bunch of awards and it
really just kind of put in perspective
it it just made me kind of think like oh
[__] yeah this is what The
state-of-the-art Cutting Edge music
videos used to be now we're to what is
going to be in another I mean that was
40 years ago but what even is going to
be in another 5 years or 10 years we
have no idea what is about to to happen
in terms of like what videos become all
right calm down with all this [__]
future [__] the point is
this you might think by The
Cars was I remember when that video
would come on television when you would
watch that that was like it well
Thriller we've said this on the show
that was an event the TV Guide you know
would tell you when Thriller was going
to be playing and you crowded around the
TV for that but even when when you might
think by The Cars plate or rocket by
Herby Hancock you were like are any of
those things well sure any of them but
those with regard to the computer
Graphics Dire Straits Money for Nothing
which was I came I think came before
that maybe after it was after this it
was after that but uh you know you were
transfixed it is a good point that you
make with regard to the tools of the
trade uh the cars are making a music
video using computer Graphics who's that
[__] commenter by name d who is that
guy who never mind uh who said some [__]
n I'm just like [__] you going to be
upset about that you're going to be
upset about all this [__] can I run
through just some more of these so we
can talk about it best male video David
Bowie China girl best female video Cindy
ler Girls Just Want to Have Fun starring
of course uh Captain Lou Albano yep best
group video zezy top legs every zezy top
video is exactly the same and all of
them I I love that one they're always
like this and they got the [__] car
uh you know uh best new artist in the
video you rhythmics Best New Artist yeah
any LS to the scene I just I think I
mentioned this on the show I just saw
her uh live at the Hollywood Bowl with
Brandy Carlile and [__] Joanie
Mitchell was there and any LX did three
she said she did no more I loves love
yous uh she did why I think she did
broken
yeah I think she have broken glass man
unbelievable to
see all this [__] best concept video
Herby Hancock Rocket best experimental
video Herby Hancock Rocket best Stage
performance in a video how could it not
be Van Halen Jump and that's when uh
David Lee Roth took the stage all Dave
all the time only on Dave
TV uh that's um that's an impress thank
you moving on okay so we had a good time
doing that seemed to me like d might not
have given a [__] about your David lero
impression that belt's mine no no no no
that's going to stay right here
obviously last week Jeremy Corbell
released some new UFO footage of a
jellyfish shaped object flying over a US
joint operations base in Iraq in October
of 2018 the object is officially
designated as a UAP by us intelligence
agencies and it is purported to have
displayed trans medium properties
although the object was imaged using
thermographic and forward-looking
infrared it displayed low observability
not appearing at all for night vision
Optical sensors and it appeared to jam
the targeting capability of the optical
platform so what's the deal guys this is
are they among us or not begin
hey I'll do this quick they are what do
you mean they are Among Us hey they are
the uh us has a military installation in
Iraq still what's going on there oh
Jesus Christ no let's talk about this
you think have you seen the video no I
haven't seen this stupid [__] video I
don't care about this video what happens
in the
video there is this jellyfish [__]
thing flying over a US military base um
that kind of phases in and out of being
detectable on these thermographic
cameras sure it does okay what do you
mean undetectable on the thermog what in
the video You See It thermographic video
is basically like it's detecting how hot
or cold it is and you just see it
switching to hot to Cold going basically
invisible in front of your [__] eyes
okay oh here you go there we go we are
looking at it right now there's a person
walking this is the the the base right
so there's this thing just [__]
flying over it Jeremy Corbell who's like
a big UFO uh researcher journalist
releases most of these videos at this
point and he's working in conjunction
with various uh intelligence agencies
and and whatever people who want to be
like whistleblowers and get this [__]
out so here it is you can see it it's
like almost see-through looking because
it's one temperature and as it keeps
going just keep watching it it'll switch
to Black look Zink okay there that means
its temperatures changed drastically and
what the [__] is this thing and now the
the real reporting on this this video he
released there and then it goes back the
video that he released is only 2 minutes
the real video is 17 minutes long and
supposedly what ends up happening is
this thing goes out of the military base
goes into a [__] Lake submerges for
multiple minutes then comes out of the
water and shoots off supposed let's see
that that's they're reporting yeah the
reporting I guess this means nothing to
you saying this we should believe that
this means nothing to you what do you
think that is I when we just watched the
uh the the MTV video music awards that
to me looks like the uh the MTV moonman
right who's just floating over letting
everyone know to watch the Video Music
Awards and then the temperature change
is because it it loads the space suit
with a fart no I'm joking here's what it
is there must have been a uh you know
the the the colonel over there at the
whatever this military installation is
had a birthday cuz my friend that just
looks like a bunch of balloons to me you
know what's weird about it that's a
bunch of balloons just floating around
let me ask you how many clusters of
balloons do you think all United States
government intelligence agencies have
classified as uaps
0.0 yeah they have all said this is a a
valid UAP they don't know what the [__]
it is there are people who are at this
uh base that are now coming out and
saying like we saw it it was weird as
[__] it was like a ghost story around
the base then this video comes out I
believe it was last Tuesday or something
MH last Friday there was a closed
Hearing in Congress about all the [__]
David grush said last year the non-human
biologics the fact that we have crashed
UFOs and we're reverse engineering them
to a [__] person yeah all these
Congress people came out of these things
where are you and I'm so sorry Eric
swell saw Crystal Clear
video and I'm an expert I'm Tom Dong
from Blink 182 I need to see some
inconclusive proof you're going to get
it inconclusive conclusive is what you
want I want yeah not inconclusive
there's a there's a that's a different
word sorry there's a video of Anna Luna
who's a a Florida congresswoman coming
out of this [__] hearing and
essentially saying uh you shouldn't be
thinking about aliens or
extraterrestrials what you should be
thinking about is extradimensional
beings and she essentially said
everything we just heard in this closed
door hearing uh corroborated everything
David grush said it is all
true I you know I don't know this okay
here okay here's my here's my this is my
thing and this has been my thing with
regard to all of this because my pal
Chow over here he uh he's into this
stuff [__] yeah dude yeah it's the next
phase of reality if we find out that
there's like extra dimensional beings or
if they're aliens whatever some new
component to like how we view existence
a big component of that I that to me is
the most important [__] happening yeah
yeah yeah yeah but the let's try it
again yeah yeah the the thing about this
only 25 that was only 25 [__]
terrible Jes worse maybe maybe I'll lose
the title yeah the belt's a little heavy
for you maybe uh here's the thing I want
to see not just the crystal clear video
I think that um the world's public at
large is not going to be interested in
any of this [__] until we have a Close
Encounters of the Fourth Kind Richard
drist type [__] yeah you know meeting
where the thing comes down we can see it
bunch of people bunch of different it we
saw it the stupid uh thing that they
made memes of the the one the the the
the thing they had in Mexico where it's
like here the the the thing and it
looked like a like a vanilla cake that's
not going to be good enough this could
also be you know some kid hung a bunch
of pots and pans off a drone I just
don't I I think that that and I know I'm
not as schooled as you are on this
footage what it looks like how important
it is that these governments and that
and all these people are saying this and
that it just doesn't [__] look like
anything to me it's just not I I'm just
saying most people aren't going to give
a
[__] but here's what's happening [__]
these videos that are coming out are
getting like closer and closer to the
crystal clear video this is the best one
that we've had and each new one that
comes out first there was the the little
shitty one that's like infrared and the
thing just kind of like twists and then
it's going and you hear the guy going oh
God what is that thing looks like [__]
the next one that comes out is a
floating pyramid moving through the sky
and you're like okay that's a little
crazier now we got a [__]
jellyfish floating over a goddamn US
base in a rack it's getting like better
and better the next one that comes out
will be better than this one so on and
so forth and my prediction that I made
on D evening of this being the year that
we get the crystal clear photo is going
to come true this would explain why it
went into the ocean and came out it's
probably you know again some some kid uh
some Army brat who's got his uh drone
dips it into the ocean and an actual
jellyfish stuck to it and now he's
trying to shake it loose and it's
turning colors cuz jellyfish do all
sorts of [__] that's where it is you
know I I'm I'm I'm with you CH in this
in this way I I do believe that it is uh
of course pretty narcissistic to think
that we are the only living beings in
the in the in the unknown Universe of
course we're not I I that's my opinion
we are absolutely not alone okay and
anyway moving on all right anyway shut
the [__] up man you know what hey hey
bro hey shut up dude shut up bro can't
wait all right what a fun show I really
had a blast today guys For The Memories
but it's time to bring 88 to a close you
scored 87 total points today bringing
you to
8,263 overall points
1,737 more points and you'll hit the
magic number 10,000 I'm getting excited
guess what next Tuesday is that's right
it's the 40th anniversary of Hulkamania
that astonishing day in 1984 when Hulk
Hogan beat the iron Chic to begin his
first reign as WWF World Heavyweight
Champion Champion hey will knock knock
who's there it's me asking you to please
dress in full Hulk Hogan cosplay for
next week's show thanks to everyone for
joining us this week today's episode was
loaded with data loads of data and you
know I'm going to use it to make next
week even better until then call me dudy
well let me tell you something dude
sometimes you got a pod show brother and
you do all sorts of voices on it dude
and you might even have an AI brother
that does its own voices dude well hold
on a sec hold on hold on hold on dude
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on that's right dude I Charmed him
to his sleep so I can make my point and
the point is this dude well next week
brother I'm going to come here in full
Hulk Hogan cosplay dude I'm going to
flip the script right now dude I'm
getting rid of kayfabe this is a shoot
brother and don't work yourself into a
shoot dude because I'm selling the game
next week brother I will be in Hulk
Hogan cosplay dude I'm not going to
screw dudes around and say oh look at
him look at the bu he's jumping on
talking too loud he loves his uncle Chad
though oh look at that oh that's so
sweet well anyway that'll be fun and
there' be no [__] reason to to do
that if I wasn't holding this that's why
this isn't going
[Music]
[Applause]
anywhere holy crap hey all right
everybody Welcome to dudy after dudy
it's the part after the show where you
know things get even more dudy because
it's after and there's two uhhuh that's
the opposite of half in a way Jesus
Christ so
uh you know it's that part of the show
where things you know the mood gets a
little more we're just going to [__]
hang out we'll probably uh get into some
gabis here in a little bit and uh just
have a chill time hope you hope you
enjoy I hope you join us on dudy plus
you know guys what an episode I'm so
pumped for this dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy plus only
at patreon.com dudy now I'm going to go
tabulate the scores and see which one of
you won the belt today just have a fun
time with each other talking about
whatever you want this is dudy after
dudy get
it dude I've been uh doing a rewatch of
louder milk now that it's on Netflix oh
yeah that's right hey louder milk is on
Netflix listen let me tell you something
louder milk has been spending some time
in the top 10 I love this show I love
everyone involved and uh am forever
grateful to Peter fairly for bringing me
on board my my gosh we are having a
great time and we can't believe that
it's uh on Netflix so please please go
uh check it out I love that show I'm
glad you're digging it yeah dude uh in
the rewatch I have noticed something in
the pilot that the main character louder
milk Ron Livingston he does something in
the pilot that you've actually done to
me in real
life what's
that please tell a friend then R
rev if you like d here's what you do
please tell a friend then
a if you like d here what you
do please tell a friend then